you work for ESPN right yes sir there's
talk now tell me if I have this right
sure that ESPN and the NFL might merge
okay some sort of deal have you heard
about this I've heard it's possible I
think it's feasible I think it's
plausible I think it's something that I
don't think we should be averse to quite
frankly see I thought you'd say
something different what I thought you'd
be scared shitless of that and I'll tell
you why okay you're a guy who's
outspoken you give your opinion about
the NFL and sometimes to the detriment
of the NFL not always you know the NFL
isn't always your favorite right if
those guys enter into a business
together I see that as dangerous so
Stephen A Smith says something
controversial about the NFL the NFL
doesn't like it they pick up the phone
to your boss at ESPN and say listen tell
that to shut up he's
pissing us off that's going to suck I
feel where you're coming from I'm G to
say what I feel I'm going to make sure
it's fact-based um more importantly I'm
going to reach out to Roger gell
directly say yo this is what I'm going
to do here's why this is where I stand
and as long as you're straight up about
where you stand you do your homework you
cultivate your sources and you have that
information then they can try to stop
you but in the end it's something that's
very very difficult to do I thought for
sure there was going to be a Revolt when
they put a game on peacock
and every if you wanted to see that game
you had to sign up for peacock that's
right 30 30 plus million watched Miami
unbelievable right did you predict that
I mean would you ever imagine that yes
million people I would have because see
look at
every moment of change in our history
it's been sparked by young people and if
you are a parent what's the number one
issue with kids I want to do what I want
to do when I want to do it how I want to
do do it without repercussions what is
it that the kid is saying let's parlay
that with the NFL I don't want to watch
it on TV I want to watch it on my phone
on my iPad or my computer I don't want
to watch it at 10:00 I want to watch it
at 1:00 or I want to watch it at 3:00 or
I want to watch it at 5:00 they want to
do what they want to do when they want
to do it how they want to do it and
here's the beauty of the National
Football League that's
unparalleled it's the one sport that
tells you emphatically you'll watch it
when we tell you to watch it you'll
watch it where we tell you to watch it
and you ain't going to do a damn thing
about it but watch it let's go back to
the whole Colin Kaepernick situation
country divided and everybody hell with
the NFL hell with the NFL until Sunday
came until Monday night came right until
Thursday night came their asses was
right in front of the TV watching the
game they can talk all the Stu they want
I know I know one dude that swears he
ain't watch football I said okay you the
fool cuz ain't nobody following you
you're a oneman March ain't nobody
follow ain't nobody marching with you on
that one they're gonna watch their
football that's the NFL and the NFL
knows that is the NFL so what do they do
they're on Direct TV what do they do
they transition to YouTube TV what do
they do not only that then they go from
YouTube TV and by the way the product
looked better okay more clear 4K
whatever the hell it is right then you
go and you say okay not NBC we going to
do peacock it's an app right and the
audience is larger than it was on Linea
television that is what the NFL is and
the NFL is spearheading and introducing
new options to the rest of the world
that the world would undoubtedly follow
the second they get an opportunity to do
so
h